la maladie de lyme n'épargne aucune
région du québec si l'estrie l'outaouais
et la montérégie sont davantage touchés
les tic se propage de plus en plus vers
le nord en raison des changements
climatiques parce que les petits mulots
les souris à pattes blanches les
chevreuils qui sont porteurs
le réservoir naturel de ce tic la migros
vers des vérins climent un peu plus
tempérée bien que les tic se retrouvent
souvent en forêt elles peuvent tout
aussi bien se situer dans des milieux
plus urbain
c'est pourquoi lors d'une randonnée en
forêt il est recommandé d'appliquer du
chasse moustiques et de porter des
vêtements longs de couleur
j'espère retrouver mon corps jours mais
pour ceux qui ont été infectés rares
sont les ressources fatigue continuelle
faiblesse musculaire migraine malgré des
symptômes reliés à la maladie de lyme
catherine breton a dû réaliser un
véritable parcours du combattant avant
d'obtenir un diagnostic
près de quinze ans plus tard je me
réveillais le matin que j'étais toujours
pour poser gt gt jamais reposé je
retournais consulter un médecin la moto
c'est de la fatigue pour le
microbiologiste et infectiologue de
montréal c'est le manque de ressources
et de recherche sur cette maladie qui
explique en partie de mauvais
diagnostics nos outils diagnostiques
c'est encore les outils diagnostiques
ont utilisé ya 30 ans quand moi j'étais
sur les bancs d'école ils sont pas très
bons mais plus de ressources verront le
jour il y à un mois québec annoncé que
des cliniques spécialisées en qu'ovide
longuet en maladie de lyme seront mis
sur pied le docteur caddie rappelle que
les pharmaciens peuvent aussi prescrire
des médicaments à ceux qui viennent
d'être piqué tout le monde ne demeurent
pas avec des problèmes prolongé
aujourd'hui suivi par le docteur khadir
catherine breton appelle tout de même à
la prudence cet été il faut vraiment
être vigilant en fait sur un pauvre
jonathan faire des activités plein air
proposée a demandé à l'est des gens avec
qui on est deux noms examinés ici
louis-philippe arsenault radio canada
québec